the caldorf fire still taking its toll
the relentless flames have been raging
in northern california for more than two
weeks now they are moving quickly toward
the popular tourist spot in south lake
tahoe near heavenly mountain resort
thank you so much for joining us at 4
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casadas so far the fire has scorched
nearly 320 miles of forest in an area
almost the size of the city of san diego
and it's only 20 percent contained
[Music]
it's a hellish scene outside south lake
tahoe's heavily mountain ski resort as
fire crews work to save it from the
fast-moving flames the resort's snow
machines are running full blast it'll
help a lot it's getting it's spreading
water out it's increasing the humidity
level it's getting everything wet
swirling gusty winds low humidity and
brush that hasn't burned in eight
decades are fueling the infernal we've
had tremendous changing wind and weather
and we're seeing fire behavior that most
could agree with me
we may never see again in our whole
lives
let's hope burning since mid-august the
kaldor fire has wiped out nearly 320
square miles of forest in northern
california's sierra nevada mountains
it's destroyed about 700 structures
mostly single family homes and
threatened at least 30 thousand more
most people have evacuated we were going
through our house you're kind of going
through the boxes and you're like okay
what can i leave behind and what do i
have to take some have stayed behind i
promised my kid i'd be out here as soon
as i saw any flames anywhere the fire is
also displacing wildlife like this bear
seen wandering around the downtown south
lake tahoe about 15 thousand
firefighters are battling the flames
some have come directly from other fires
officials are urging crews to pace
themselves we all know we still have a
long grind ahead of us not only do we
recognize the physical fatigue
but equally important is the mental
fatigue while crews are making progress
they'll be battling adverse conditions
for weeks to come
just heartbreaking images there well
firefighters in california have been
battling the flames around the clock for
days so local crews are now there
helping in the relief those include the
north las vegas fire department and
clark county fire department while
they're not on the front lines they're
handling daily medical calls or other
smaller fires in the area so california
crews can focus on the cal door fire
for us to be able to come into their
stations and provide them
a little bit of of a break to get their
lives back in order get reset again to
go back and engage in the wildfire
it's an amazing experience for us we're
extremely happy to be here and provide
that for them
our crews are expected to be there for
at least
two weeks to provide assistance but
we're told that timeline could change